hemos hablado mucho acerca del sistema
linfático y en este vídeo quiero hablar
sobre la linfa que es el fluido del
sistema linfático sabemos que la linfa
proviene originalmente de la sangre pues
es el fluido que es exprimido o
expulsado de los vasos sanguíneos
imaginemos que esto que estoy dibujando
es un capilar estas son las células
endoteliales del capilar así que la
linfa es el líquido que es expulsado a
través de estos pequeños huecos que se
encuentran en el capilar y para tener
bien la terminología la linfa se llama
así una vez que ha llegado al vaso
linfático por lo que es hasta que este
fluido entra aquí que podemos llamarlo
linfa pero no antes antes de entrar al
vaso linfático este fluido se llama
fluido extracelular porque se encuentra
fuera de las células que están aquí
aunque la composición básica del fluido
es la misma sólo es cuestión de
semántica en este vídeo vamos a conocer
qué es lo que forma la linfa y para
hacerlo vamos a comenzar con la sangre
pues originalmente surge de ella
de sangre hay glóbulos rojos cr que
dibujamos aquí aunque en realidad
deberíamos dibujar muchos más de los que
he dibujado aquí ya que el 40% de la
sangre está formada por los glóbulos
rojos en una persona promedio si una
persona tiene anemia tendrá menos
glóbulos rojos si el 40% de la sangre
está formada de glóbulos rojos entonces
he dibujado muy pocos aquí pero sería
difícil dibujar todos los glóbulos rojos
en la proporción correcta por lo que lo
voy a dejar así además de esto tenemos
agua que la dibujo en color blanco y
también hay proteínas que dibujo en
varios tamaños porque las proteínas
tienen diversos tamaños y hay varios
tipos de proteínas en la sangre que
hacen diferentes cosas es todo lo que
dibujaremos aquí aunque también hay
moléculas de glucosa lípidos y otras
cosas en la sangre pero podemos
ignorarlas por ahora y qué es lo que
sale por aquí que es lo que sale
exprimido sabemos que los glóbulos rojos
son muy grandes como para ser expulsados
así que para cuando tenemos algo del
fluido extracelular aquí
y un 0% de glóbulos rojos la linfa no
tiene glóbulos rojos pero además de eso
permítanme preguntarles creen que la
linfa tiene mayor o menor concentración
de proteínas que la sangre esta es una
pregunta difícil porque si toda la
proteína saliera libremente de estos
vasos entonces la linfa tendría una
mayor concentración de proteínas que la
sangre debido a que la sangre tiene más
glóbulos rojos que ocupan espacio
podríamos decir que la proteína está
diluida en esta cantidad enorme de
glóbulos rojos y aquí afuera no está
diluida entre glóbulos rojos pero en
realidad hay menos proteínas en la linfa
que en la sangre esto es debido a que el
agua sale con mayor facilidad de estos
capilares en comparación con las
proteínas por lo que aquí queda un
fluido bastante diluido a las proteínas
les es difícil salir de los capilares
aunque algunas logran hacerlo por lo que
dibujo algunas aquí pero hay menos que
en la sangre en la linfa hay de un medio
a un tercio de proteínas en comparación
con la que hay en la sangre vamos
así otra cosa que podemos preguntarnos
es qué tipos de proteínas van a llegar a
la linfa ya que mencionamos que hay
muchos tipos de proteínas en la sangre
cuáles van a llegar a la linfa pues van
a ser las más pequeñas ya que son las
que más fácilmente pueden pasar entre
estos espacios podemos decir por ejemplo
que la proporción de las proteínas
pequeñas como la albúmina con respecto a
las proteínas grandes como la
inmunoglobulina que abrevió como ig y
que son anticuerpos más grandes que la
albúmina la proporción de la albúmina
respecto a la inmunoglobulina es mayor
en la linfa que en la sangre esto se
debe a lo que mencionamos antes a que la
albúmina es más pequeña que la
inmunoglobulina por lo que le es más
sencillo pasar por estos espacios en
comparación con las proteínas más
grandes así que aunque hubiera menos
albúmina en general en la linfa
comparada con la de la sangre habrá una
mayor proporción de albúmina que de
inmunoglobulina en la linfa hagamos una
pausa antes de dejar de hablar de las
proteínas en la linfa
ya que es muy importante que exista una
menor cantidad de proteínas en la linfa
que en la sangre si vieron uno de los
primeros vídeos recordarán que
mencionamos que la forma en que el
fluido es expulsado fuera de los
capilares no es tan simple ya que lo que
sucede es que primero el fluido es
exprimido y después algo de ese fluido
regresa al capilar y la razón de esto es
porque conforme se viaja por el capilar
disminuye la presión hidrostática que
hizo que este fluido fuera expulsado por
lo que hay menor presión empujando el
fluido hacia afuera pero aún hay algo de
presión haciendo esto así que porque
algo de este fluido regresa al vaso
sanguíneo la razón es porque existe una
mayor concentración de cosas como las
proteínas aquí y está mayor
concentración hace que la sangre sea
osmótica mente activa aunque esto suena
intimidante por lo que hay una mayor
presión osmótica que hace que regrese
algo del fluido justamente porque hay
más proteínas en la sangre que en la
linfa es por eso que es muy importante
que haya más proteínas en la sangre que
en lalín
ahora quiero preguntarles qué tanta
cantidad de linfa creen que producimos
cada día la cantidad de linfa producida
es la cantidad de líquido que es
expulsado fuera de estos vasos
sanguíneos menos la cantidad de líquido
que regresa al vaso sanguíneo cuánto
creen que se acumula durante el día
cuánta linfa se produce al día voy a
darles un momento para que piensen en
esto y traten de adivinar la respuesta
así que traten de pensar en la cantidad
de litros de linfa que se producen en el
día y la respuesta es 3 litros se
producen 3 litros de linfa al día esta
es la cantidad de fluido que se filtra
fuera de los capilares esa es la palabra
que usan las personas para describir
esto filtrar y resulta que la cantidad
de líquido que sale al principio son 20
litros y lo dibujo pequeño aquí ya que
son pequeños detalles que no necesitan
saber así que son 20 litros los que son
expulsados después 17 litros regresan de
nuevo por lo que queda una diferencia de
3 litros que salen cada día
esto es por día la última cosa que debo
mencionar es que la linfa tiene una
composición diferente dependiendo de su
ubicación en el cuerpo vamos a dibujar
rápidamente una silueta humana para
darnos una idea de cómo es que la linfa
difiere dependiendo de su ubicación aquí
está la silueta de un cuerpo y una cosa
que mencionamos es como en el intestino
delgado los vasos linfáticos que aquí se
llaman vasos kylie feroz llevan muchas
grasas o quilo micrones por lo que
pueden imaginar que la composición de la
linfa que sale de aquí va a tener más
kilómetro nes que son colecciones de
grasas o lípidos en comparación con la
región del hígado esto es algo que no
necesariamente necesitan saber pero el
hígado produce muchísimas proteínas que
terminan en la sangre y una de las
formas en las que éstas llegan a la
sangre es entrando primero en la linfa
por lo que la linfa que viene del hígado
tiene una mayor concentración de
proteínas que la linfa de otras partes
del cuerpo la linfa que viene del hígado
puede tener hasta 10 veces más proteínas
que la linfa de otras partes del cuerpo
el rango de aquí de un medio a un tercio
es en realidad un promedio de toda la
linfa de todo el cuerpo ya que la
concentración de proteínas varía mucho
de un lugar a otro como sabemos todos
los vasos linfáticos incluyendo los kill
y feroz del intestino delgado se van a
juntar y aún ir para viajar hacia arriba
en el cuerpo donde regresarán a la
circulación por las venas que se
encuentran aquí que dibujo en azul
aunque esto se está volviendo algo
confuso las dibujo en azul porque
generalmente las venas se dibujan en
color azul y estas venas se unen y
llegan al corazón
todos estos diferentes fluidos
linfáticos con composiciones diferentes
se van a unir y van a regresar a la
circulación